juba un giuda ragazzi allora siamo
all'aeroporto di milano malpensa allora
io non ve l'ho detto non ve l'ho detto
perché sono uno stronzo stiamo andando
ragazzi a new orleans 16 casse di
orleans dove fanno il jazz sulla musica
tipo martin garris tornando con questo
tamarro con questo tamarro schifoso ci
vediamo sull'aereo direttamente me la
spiego questa roba
voi che state vedendo quelle luci che
lampeggiano notte su tutto aereo ci sono
le luci che lampeggiano su tutto l'aereo
e voi direte che cazzo succede infermi
in realtà queste luci con sarno
assolutamente lampeggiando siete poi che
le vedete lampeggiare perché questa
videocamera non so per quale motivo
appoggiare le luci non noi bene il
perché
quindi da da tutto un tocco disco a
questo blog
anche se divisi milano trio è
stranissima questa cosa non capisco
perché è un altro mondo attraverso
questa videocamera fantastico rende
anche le persone belle vediamo no
funziona
poiché i ragazzi siamo atterrati a new
york
esprimiamo a far scalo per new orleans
abbiamo tipo tre ore di attesa quella
eroporto quindi sono venuti a mangiare
il ristorante san valentino mangiare con
un attivo in questi posti quanti
romantici col fiore invece mi trovo
stage e capua
andiamo ad analizzare bene questo menu
metti lingua italiana italiana se poi
vai su bevande e se vai tutti in fondo
classico nero ha ghiacciato il tempo che
la ghiacciato state morgan freeman
bambini sotto i 12 anni
ok voglio comprare questa cosa formaggio
la griglia e dottor pepper perfetto
ordine
la preghiamo in che senso aveva vj che
cazzo mi pregano a fare
prosegui favismo 6 religioso da
preghiamo io lascerò questo sfondo su
questo tablet per tutto il tempo
così franz eroe guarderò questa foto
macché ma che cazzo
[Musica]
rifai blog in giro e che devo
registrarmi anche la mattina e quando mi
registrano la mattina è sempre
bellissimo voi laga suoi allora siamo
cioè mi sono alzato adesso sono le s
sono le la c'è scritto 832 ma in realtà
sono le 7 32 perché c'è l'orologio che
indietro e va bene ci siamo alzati
adesso e sto dormendo in stanza con
lorenzo che in bagno meno male perché
era in mutande
vi ho risparmiato questa scena ieri
siamo arrivati che era notte fonda
quindi perché abbiamo fatto veramente un
viaggio della madonna siamo arrivati
abbiamo messo 12 anni per arrivare qua
irraggiungibile new orleans e quindi
niente ci siamo buttati nel letto io
ancora non ho visto come fuori nel senso
che era notte quindi non si vedeva un
cazzo quindi adesso scopriamo insieme
sotto c'è una barca comunque quello del
mississipi italia ma doc e bombara
dell'influenza francese quindi grazie a
dio ci abbiamo quel budget on che sta in
bagno che sa parlare francese
eccolo a chi no che il mio letto dai no
perché abbiamo dormito 6 ore quindi è
normale che sia stanco però c'è il jet
lag ragazzi un macello non latin america
non riuscite mai a dormire quanto
vorreste perché il jetlag di ammazza
delle mutande comunque molto bella e
capodanno niente pensa invece io volevo
stare con una bella [ __ ] chi si lanciava
sul letto così una bella gnocca
invece no c'è più belli di me quest'uomo
ecco cosa cazzo famiglia l'ho sentito
fino qua il botto
le passa al suo massimo fino alla plebe
oppure la cosa più [ __ ] che io abbia mai
visto perché tipo non è metropoli e tipo
un america old style stranissima c'è
cosa di gta che basta in mezzo i figli
siano reja comunque viola ma la barba di
arte qualcosa che io non avrò mai nella
vita
la notte con questo pasqua c'è possiamo
chiedergli un pezzo di barba guardali
che fa il fan sconto vale un pezzo di
barba sua la vediamo su ebay
[Musica]
niente ragazzi stiamo fingendo
giornalisti per per fare il fango è in
rotta non siamo giornalisti ma le ha
studiate guarda riesco a zoomarle anche
il baffo sinistro sono proprio un gran
reporter cellule b sei proprio un
deficit fatto passa questa bella ciao
quanto costa questa per la maglietta di
chi gira gira gira e tira quanto passa
ma perché volo mi sta riprendendo
porca pippen quanto vuoi zio però se vai
miglior rendimento niente né vedere cosa
sta para ma perché si dona carnevale qua
ma in italiano e carnevale non ancora
allora perché anno il carnevale tipo
francese si chiama mara di gara ma cos'è
che sto vedendo le danni e tra dieci
anni
ciao danni e defant hellas sebach ad un
piccolo
riportiamo o palline
marchiano io sei grande mela si sta
fissando da ridere
beh ragazzi favi in cornetto carnevale
mardi gras di mardi gras ma perché si
dice mattina ti regala le cose ma avrò
di amarti gr1 chiti non c'è fuori a casa
questo paese sa qualcosa che non va come
ci sono dei problemi in tutto però va
beh
bella [ __ ] allora ragazzi quello che
avete visto era il primo giorno a new
orleans l'unico che abbiamo fatto
infatti vide un po corto scusatemi ma è
l'unico giorno che abbiamo fatto qui non
avevo tante riprese da domani iniziano i
giorni quelli power quindi con i
contenuti quelli belli potenti e vi
sparo al prossimo vlog che sarà
veramente una bomba ragazzi comunque
spero domani mattina che lorenzo si sia
trasformato in una bella gnocca c'è
possibilità che succeda se c'è
possibilità che succede quindi ragazzi
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
conclude questo primo episodio a new
orleans e quindi ragazzi come al solito
momento non mi piace anche marie social
che come visto tornare descrizione di
scadere ci dividiamo un prossimo video
poi mettete mi piace sono diventate così
nel comando il telecomando ecco che di
video che i video che vi direbbe la
ragazzi ragazzi perfetto